there's so many video streaming services
right now netflix disney plus hbo max
nbc universal blah blah blah they just
launched the peacock streaming service
you'd think that's more than enough
right you think that would be all you'd
need like we're all done
but guess what if you did guess that
you'd be wrong
because yet another new video streaming
service
launched just today that's right
take a look in the past four months zoom
has become a way of life
and now that trend continues with the
latest video streaming service
zoom to the max thanks to our policy of
secretly recording
every zoom meeting ever held zoom to the
max can now offer you a streaming
library of literally
millions of videos including such
classics as
the co-workers who stay on zoom after a
meeting to trash everyone else
you guys see that uh his virtual
background was his daughter's princeton
acceptance letter
i'm still here
yeah we knew that obligatory chats with
your parents
i mean her father wasn't in the best of
help
he was pretty obese i don't know what
the family was eating but whatever
she was pretty chunky looking too the
other day when i saw her
getting on a zoom meeting on the wrong
day
hey guys
the best and poorly lit meetings and you
know that
each of you uh belongs to a different uh
team zoom bloopers so we'd probably be
better off going with a motherboard that
has an integrated 10 gigabit ethernet
connection that way
zoom tinder dates oh my god
yeah zoom bloopers volume two just for
our third quarter goals if we could make
sure that
and volume three so we don't have to
worry about wasting a lot of time
rebuilding volumes in the event
i'm okay zoom to the max
because quiddy lowered the bar